[Musique]
bonjour moïse lagarrigue
sapeurs-pompiers à saint pierre depuis
1990 à côté de ça je suis président de
l'association réalisé du cap qui est
situé très sensible sur la la pauvreté
sur l'inaccessibilité pour des familles
de mon quartier par exemple nena
beaucoup de choses que banane après
surtout les enfants surtout les enfants
des jeunes filles qui accouche d enfants
ils sont encore à l'école et eux-mêmes
et sont encore des enfants donc la
transmission de l'amour à l'enfant c'est
quelque chose d'important et donc nous
notre gestion est justement et mettre
des actions en place qui est la fonction
parentale expliqué apparent ben comment
comment donner la moisson enfants comme
ordonné l'éducation à son enfant
je suis père de famille g55 enfants dans
les années 2000 ont été appelés en
intervention en tant que professionnel
sapeurs-pompiers et ont été appelés pour
un feu à deux bébés c'était au pied de
l'église à saint pierre et là on arrive
on rouvre un petit sac ont découvert un
nouveau-né tout le corps maculé de sang
quand on quitte avec le cordon ombilical
ou donc ça ça m'a marqué parce que je
suis kaka très sensible au sujet des
enfants donc samara sa maman qui
l'intervention pareil et nour à l'époque
on n'avait pas de filles à la maison on
n'avait que des garçons donc c'est dire
tiens voilà c'est l'occasion on va quoi
il y aura une fille et qui m'est passé
l'idée du diable on va adopter cet
enfant donc on a les deux mini notre
fille aujourd'hui elle a 18 ans
d'ailleurs elle est en contrat civique
chez nous à l'association alisée du cap
les associations sont pas propres à ces
prises en compte dans le travail social
culturel et sportif que les h en face on
est mélangé comme toutes les entreprises
est souvent les associations ne réussit
il réussit pas pour ça parce que les
taxis parce que bon la payer en retard
tout agenda l'autre dépend des
subventions
je pense qu'on devait donner un peu plus
de liberté et distingue les les
associations c'est que nous marchons et
le smi d'associations secteur marchand
et les entreprises